on direct avec nous pour en parler
octave daube et des porte parole du
mouvement étudiant koeman de
l'université libre de bruxelles merci
d'être en direct avec ou bienvenue sur
rt france on a vu des milliers de jeunes
rassemblés aujourd'hui à glasgow pour
dénoncer l'inaction des dirigeants et
quel impact peut avoir cette
manifestation pleine 4,26
l'interview excusez moi j'ai un peu la
voix cassée après la grande aide et
action d'aujourd'hui m on espère avant
tout avec ce genre de manifestation soit
ici à glasgow on est venus avec 200
d'étudiants de deux prises de toute la
belgique avec comac connecteurs avoir
comme point d'entrée manifestation s'est
tenue chez les dirigeants à prendre des
mesures à n'importe lesquels on reçoit
des mesures qui aillent qui a été
maintenant de prendre leurs
responsabilités aux couleurs d'un pays
aux grandes multinationales qui polluent
et pas aux gens du quotidien avec des
textures des attaques illégales contre
des convois voir comment pas que
vous vous parlais à l'instant de mesures
concrètes tant que vous voulez koné chef
des tonnes et dirigeants prennent
aujourd'hui précisément quelles sont ces
mesures dont vous parlez
les mesures qu'il faut prendre par
exemple écrit l'on nous donc moi je suis
en train de commettre le mouvement et
qui tente du travail de belgique
et nous on pense qu'il est temps il est
grand temps de s'en prendre aux
multinationales polluantes en leur
donnant des normes contraignantes en
belgique 40 % la production des
émissions qu'elle a été représentée
international polluantes et ont fait car
rien de concret et c'est alors
maintenant vous devez payer et
transformez votre production pour
baisser vos décisions de guerre nous la
première mesure c'est des normes
contraignantes ensuite celle des mesures
aussi très concrète et qui faillit faut
que ces mesures elle dali systématique
existe-t-elle comme par exemple le
remboursement est la gratuité des
transports évite
par exemple parmi les plus grandes
mesures
qui se forme à temps et ne sont pas du
tout prix à l'échelle de la belgique ou
à l'échelle européenne
alors pour revenir sur les propos de
grains ta mère on vient de l'apprendre à
l'adie laquelle il fut en tout cas cette
coque 26 d'échec et vous quelle est
votre position personnelle vous en
attendez plus rien de sa coque dans six
mois à peine on n'est pas encore finie
là on va évidemment de convoiter que la
coop anti el banques dont 10 filles au
bon moment les d'état met des plantes
n'ont vraiment pas du tout à la hauteur
du défi climatique dont on a besoin
et on est effectivement si on est parti
comme ça on va pas repartir et
comme l'état ce qui est important est
que même qui est du plan sont pas
attendu la cop16 elle
elle n'a pas l'air d'aller dans la bonne
direction la mobilisation les
manifestations étaient très inflammables
a un impact était d'attaqué aujourd'hui
qu'il pleuve on n'y arrive pas on
n'arrivera pas demain et pourquoi on
doit continuer à acquitter à le
décourager et qu'on a
on n'a pas le soir et on a besoin d'un
grand soir entre en action un peu pété
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
on dirait que sur arte france octave
dont je rappelle que vous êtes le porte
parole du mouvement étudiant comac de
l'université libre de bon élève vous
avez manifesté aujourd'hui pour dénoncer
selon vous l'inaction climatique des
dirigeants merci à vous